hey craig hey martin what are you
working on
[Music]
i built a web app and a mobile app that
display info about famous artists
it is backed by a simple rest api
running on cloud run
but when users are reporting that it's
sometimes slow can you help me speed it
up
yeah absolutely it sounds like you might
need a caching layer
let me show you how it's done great
all right craig so here is my api uh
if i hit the url here it takes three
seconds to respond
three seconds what does your code look
like
yeah here it is this call here runs a
complex database query
it takes several seconds to complete i
see
so you could try to save recently
accessed artists in a cache and that
would make your slow database query run
less often and it looks like your data
structure here is pretty simple just an
id
that points to an object and that really
lends itself to a key value cache
okay sounds good can you show me how to
do it
absolutely click memory store in the
cloud console
and memory store is built to handle
exactly this kind of caching
okay uh i will pick redis for now
and i'm enabling memory store in this
project
okay great now click create instance
and give it an instanced name and
display name
and then for the rest of the fields the
defaults are fine
so you should be able to click the
create button
now your reddit server is being
initialized and this server sits in a
virtual private cloud so it's not
accessible from the outside internet
that means the next thing we need to do
is set up a connector so that your cloud
run service can connect
to this virtual private cloud and to do
that
first pick vpc network in the navigation
sidebar
then click serverless vpc access
now click create connector give it the
name
myvpc connector under
network pick default and under
subnet pick ip range
now in the text box enter the suggested
value of 10.8.0.0 that works great
and click the create button
now let's head back over to memory store
and copy the ip address of the redis
instance that we just created
now in your deployment script add redis
host
redis port and vpc connector as
environment variables
okay uh now that is done i will enter
the code snippet you sent me
awesome that snippet creates a redis
client object so that your other code
can use that to access the cache
and then instead of calling get artists
from database we can call a new function
get artist from cache now in this new
get artist from cache
method the first three lines simply make
the redis client use promises instead of
callbacks and
this just makes your code easier to read
then the code checks to see if the
artist with the given id is in the cache
if it isn't it calls get artist from
database and puts that artist
in the cache finally it reads the
artist's record from the cache and
returns
it all right
okay i'm deploying the updated code to
cloud run
very good the code is now deployed i'm
hitting the url now
oh it's still as slow as before craig
yes of course because the artist is not
yet in the cache on that first request
but if you reload the page i think it'll
be a lot faster
okay uh reloading oh that was a lot
faster
cool but what if i need to update that
artist's record in the database
well then you'll need to update it in
the cache too i sent you some more code
for that did you get it
ah yes uh let's see entering it now
okay great so this method uses the
request payload to update both the cash
value
and any database records so the cash is
never stale
excellent let me redeploy the api
now back to postman here i have a put
request
that will add the field movement to
frida kahlo's artist record
she belonged to the surrealism movement
well that's perfect
because you're going to have a surreally
fast api with all this caching
maybe don't quit your day job craig all
right
now to reread that artist's data ah
and here it is with the new movement
field added and it was
very quick served from the cache thanks
for helping me speed up my api craig
happy to help now right now your code is
using the read through and
right through caching strategies and
they work pretty well for most
applications but you might also want to
search online for some other caching
patterns in case those work better for
your app
now also remember that your code can
never count on this object being in the
cache that's why we still have the
database backing it up
when a cache fills up it can kick out
objects at any time
all right thank you for that reminder
craig
and thank you everyone for watching you
will find a link to the code and to the
memory store documentation
in the description below please let us
know in the comments if you found this
episode useful
or if you have suggestions for future
episodes
happy caching
[Music]
you